Taco?
Yes.
In the seal teams you lead all male teams.
Any leadership difference?
In business?
We're in the business world with mixed gender or female teams,
so first of all in the military did work with woman.
There's what?
There's no women in seal teams,
but there's women that are Intel.
There's women that are in logistics.
There's women in in the,
some of the logistics support units that go out in the field sometimes.
So definitely worked with women in the military and in the civilian sector with
the,
with echelon front and work with all kinds of women,
all kinds of women in every level.
From CEOs on down to frontline troopers.
And here's the deal.
For me,
it's no factor,
no factor to me.
What's a factor to me is can they do their job?
Do they have an open mind?
Are they humble?
Do they treat people with respect?
Those are the kinds of things that I'm judging.
It's like what we talked about earlier.
I'm judging,
but I'm not judging based on what they are.
I'm judging on who they are and who they are as a person.
So that's the,
I I see no real difference.
The leadership,
the way that you lead doesn't change,
in my opinion,
from the,
from the women I've seen in leadership positions to the men of senior leadership
positions.
The,
the way they lead is successful because of the way they lead,
not because they're male or female.
And you know,
some of the stereotypes that that you might see out there,
um,
like he,
like,
like for instance,
men are tougher than women or,
or men or women are more emotional than men.
That's just garbage.
Jane,
if you see,
I've seen at least when you get to a leadership position,
I've definitely seen women that were way tougher than than guys were in terms
of,
hey,
we've got to make this move for the company.
Here's what I'm going to do.
Boom.
They execute it.
And I've seen men that were way too emotional attached to this scenario and ruin
it because they're just way more emotional than this stereotypical woman might
be.
So that's why I just didn't,
don't think you can trust them.
I look at a person,
not whether they're a man or a woman.
I'm looking at their,
the content of their character for the second time.
I'll say that today.
MLK.
Um,
and now when we start talking about combat,
um,
there's some physical differences that make that make a definite impact.
And I talked about on the Tim Kennedy,
if you want to hear ever hear me talk about that because yeah,
when you get into some physical things,
men are stronger than women.
And so there's a,
there's some physical limitations there,
but in terms of leadership capabilities in the,
in the civilian sector,
there's,
yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not worried about men and women.
Yeah.
Okay.
Are there some nuances there?
There are.
There are new eds for instance,
who were like,
one you'll hear as,
um,
I'll get asked,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a female and I'm in charge of these guys.
Uh,
you know,
how should I act or what should I do?
Well,
cause they,
they might not like working for a firm,
for a girl.
Right.
And I say,
well,
they probably,
that that guy probably wouldn't like working for a guy either or a free younger
guy or for a guy that got moved from another department.
There's,
it's the same thing.
It's the same thing.
So what are you going to do?
I always say be humble.
Listen to what they have to say.
Keep an open mind.
That's what you're going to do regardless.
Male,
female,
whatever.
It just,
you older,
younger,
doesn't matter.
You want it.
The being a good leader,
the principles don't change.
That's all there is to it.
Yeah.
Cause yeah,
cause in as an insecure guy getting sick,
getting laid or,
or,
or a girl calling shots or whatever will affect them.
[inaudible] but like you said,
if they,
if their leadership principles are sound and they're making the right call,
it's going to be obvious that like,
that guy's messing up or you know,
like he's,
he's,
um,
acting out of insecurity that we're not acting out of insecurity.
It's going to be obvious the leadership part,
as long as that sound,
you're going to have success.
Yeah.
So,
yeah.
Um,
that's no factor to me.
Yeah.
Next question.
Maybe I should bring some of the female leaders that I've worked with on the
podcast.
You know,
the thing,
the problem with that is there are no different than the male leaders I've
worked with,
so I'm sure that there's some,
some women would listen to this and they go,
oh,
you don't know how hard it is when x all you don't know.
I am.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like though,
good female leaders I've worked with have been like,
oh yeah,
that can be sometimes a problem because I'm a woman and here's what I do to
negate it.
Because guess what?
The next day I'll be working with a different client and the,
it's a man and he goes,
well,
you know,
I have to deal with x and this is how I mitigate it.
So everyone's dealing with x.
Everyone's got some factor that they're trying to overcome and it just,
the good leader,
we'll find a way around that factor or find a way to mitigate that factor and a
bad leader won't.
And we'll then use that factor as an excuse,
right.
Rather than just as an advantage.
You know,
there's a huge difference between taking ownership of these problems and saying,
oh,
you don't want to,
here's the issue.
Okay,
I'm going to own that.
I'm going to take care of it.
I'm going to find a way around it.
Instead of saying,
Oh,
I'm younger,
I'm older,
I'm a woman,
I'm a man trying to lead these.
It's like,
no,
you're,
you're a human leading another human being.
And so step up and lead,
figure out what the issues are and overcome them.